Тут все - наші поля!
24-річний Євген Нагірний на своїй фермі площею 600 гектарів вирощує пшеницю, кукурудзу, буряк та інші овочі.
Врожай пшениці, зібраний цього літа, все ще у зерносховищі.
Через війну українську пшеницю практично неможливо вивезти з країни.
Ціна на зерно Євгена Нагірного впала майже удвічі.
Наразі в нас 5000-6000 гривень за тонну, що набагато нижче собівартості.
І нам доводиться його (зерно) тримати на складі з надією, що найближчим часом щось зміниться.
Атмосфера у господарстві напружена. Російські ракети вже падали на прилеглі поля.
Молодий фермер відчуває відповідальність не лише за свій бізнес, але й за безпеку своїх близьких - маму і брата.
Незважаючи на те, що з серпня у рамках зернової угоди з Росією експорт українського зерна відновився,
Євген Нагірний ще не відчув полегшення.
Це чудово, що є така можливість, і вона продовжується для відправки нашого зерна.
І сподіваємося, що так буде і надалі, і ціни на нашому ринку стабілізуються.
Наразі з українських портів завдяки зерновій угоді експортували понад 11 мільйонів тонн зерна та продовольства.
Однак до війни країна щомісяця відправляла п’ять мільйонів тонн продовольства.
Через те, що ціна на зерно впала, Євгенові не вистачає грошей на паливо. Ціна дизелю зросла вдвічі.
А добрива нині втричі дорожчі - якщо їх взагалі можна десь роздобути.
Аби утримати бізнес на плаву, молодому хліборобу доводиться ухвалювати складні рішення.
Доводиться зменшувати кількість добрив.
За рахунок високої вартості ми не можемо собі дозволити давати таку саму норму, як в минулі роки.
І доводиться оптимізувати собівартість до цього року, але за рахунок зменшення кількості добрив і хімії - засобів захисту.
Оскільки прибуток наступного року також під великим знаком питання,
Євгену, ймовірно, важко буде виплачувати зарплату своїм працівникам.
Частина з них лише нещодавно приїхала сюди зі сходу України, де точаться активні бойові дії.
Євген дав їм роботу і житло на фермі. І відчуває, що зобов’язаний і надалі підтримувати їх.
Тут якраз живуть переселенці з Харкова. Зараз вони ремонт собі роблять.
Тут маємо підлогу доробити, тут будуть інші меблі. Ліжко замовили і допомагаємо, як можемо.
Через війну в Україні внутрішніми переселенцями стали понад шість з половиною мільйонів українців.
Багато з них живуть у сусідньому Львові.
Львів’янка Наталія Квик до війни була успішною бізнес-леді.
Рік тому вона з чоловіком вирішила інвестувати в сільське господарство.
На заощадження придбали ферму площею 380 гектарів за 30 хвилин їзди від Львова,
де хотіли вирощувати ячмінь і сою.
Ми нові в цьому бізнесі. І коли ми почали працювати, ми стикнулися після початку повномасштабної війни
з подорожчанням усіх витратних матеріалів, які були пов’язані з вирощуванням зернових культур.
Але ми не зупинилися, ми працюємо і будемо працювати й надалі.
І віримо, що це дійсно принесе успіх і ми робимо дійсно добру справу.
Наталія Квик переконана, що фермери відіграють вирішальну роль у виживанні країни під час війни.
Але як довго вона ще зможе утримувати свій бізнес на плаву?
Цей урожай, який ми зібрали, його потрібно вивезти і продати.
Ті об’єми, які Україна зараз може вивозити, це дуже малі об’єми порівняно з тим, що було раніше.
На кордонах просто шалені черги. Логістика з’їдає більшу частину вартості зерна, за яку раніше ми могли би його продавати.
Євген шукає додаткові джерела доходу, аби мати змогу продовжувати свій бізнес.
Одне з них - здача в оренду приміщення на своїй фермі для виробництва туалетного паперу.
Завдяки цьому він може платити зарплату працівникам та покривати інші потреби на фермі.
Молодий хлібороб продовжує вірити, що його праця допомагає Україні вистояти
і що одного дня такі, як він, зможуть повернути процвітання своїй батьківщині,
займаючись тим, що люблять робити найбільше - фермерством.
Я з дитинства любив вирощувати, і зараз я пишу це поле, як поет книжку.
Зерно Євгена Нагірного - це порятунок для людей на його фермі, для його громади,
але також для багатьох людей у всьому світі.
До війни, у 2021 році, Україна була шостим найбільшим виробником пшениці у світі,
і давала десяту частину світового експорту.